what is the most beautiful motion of a
animal or robot that you've ever seen
i think the most beautiful motion of a
robot has to be the passive dynamic
walkers
i think there's just something
fundamentally beautiful the ones in
particular that steve collins built with
andy rowena
at cornell a 3d walking machine
so it was not confined to a boom or a
plane
that you put it on top of a small ramp
give it a little push
it's powered only by gravity no
controllers no batteries whatsoever
it just falls down the ramp and at the
time
it looked more natural more graceful
more human-like
than any robot we'd seen to date powered
only by gravity
how does it work well okay the simplest
model is kind of like a slinky it's like
an elaborate slinky
one of the simplest models we use to
think about it is actually a rimless
wheel
so imagine taking a bike's bicycle wheel
but take the rim off
so it's now just got a bunch of spokes
if you give that a push
it still wants to roll down the ramp but
every time its foot
its spoke comes around and hits the
ground it loses a little energy
every time it takes a step forward it
gains a little energy
those things can come into perfect
balance and actually they
they want to it's a stable phenomenon if
it's going too slow it'll speed up
if it's going too fast it'll slow down
and it comes into a stable periodic
motion
now you can take that rimless wheel
which doesn't look very much like a
human walking
take all the extra spokes away put a
hinge in the middle now it's two legs
that's called our compass gate walker
that can still you give it a little push
starts falling down a ramp looks a
little bit more like walking
at least it's a biped but what
steve and andy and ted mcgear started
the whole exercise but what steve and
andy did was they took it to this
beautiful conclusion where they built
something that had knees
arms a torso the arms swung naturally
give it a little push and that looked
like a stroll through the park
how do you design something like that i
mean is that art or science
it's on the boundary i think there's a
science to getting
close to the solution i think there's
certainly art in the way that they
they made a beautiful robot but um
but then the finesse because because
this was work
they were working with a system that
wasn't perfectly modeled wasn't
perfectly controlled
there's all these little tricks that you
have to tune the suction cups at the
knees for instance so that they
stick but then they release at just the
right time or there's all these little
tricks of the trade
which really are art but it was a point
i mean it made the point
we were at that time the walking robot
the best walking robot in the world was
honda's asimo
absolutely marvel of modern engineering
is this 90s
this was in 97 when they first released
it sort of announced p2 and then it went
through it was asimo by then
in 2004
and it looks like this very cautious
walking
like you're walking on on hot coals or
something like that
i think it gets a bad rap asimo is a
beautiful machine it does walk with its
knees bent
our atlas walking had its knees bent but
actually asimo was pretty fantastic
but it wasn't energy efficient neither
was atlas
when we worked on atlas none of our
robots
that have been that complicated have
been very energy efficient
but there was a there's a thing that
happens when you do control
when you try to control a system of that
complexity you try to use your motors to
basically
counteract gravity take whatever the
world's doing to you and push back
erase the dynamics of the world and
impose the dynamics you want because you
can make them simple
and analyzable mathematically simple
and this was a very sort of beautiful
example that you don't have to do that
you can just let go let physics do most
of the work
right and you just have to give it a
little bit of energy this one only
walked down a ramp it would never walk
on the flat
to walk on the flat you have to give a
little energy at some point
but maybe instead of trying to take the
forces imparted to you by the world
and replacing them what we should be
doing is letting the world push us
around
and we go with the flow very zen very
zen robot
yeah but okay so that sounds very zen
but you can i can also imagine
how many like failed
versions they had to go through like how
many like
i would say it's probably would you say
it's in the thousands that they've had
to have
the system fall down before they figured
out
how they could i don't know if it's
thousands but uh it's a lot it takes
some patience there's no question
so in that sense control might help a
little bit
oh the abs i think everybody even at the
time
said that the answer is to do with that
with control but it was just pointing
out
that maybe the way we're doing control
right now isn't the way we should
you